to embarrass here author the 4-hour
workweek want to talk about and uses
this is a common problem area for people
to read the 4-hour workweek and that is
creating a cash flow based business and
automated business that funds your
lifestyle so it's not intended to be
sold necessarily although that can
happen it has happened with readers so I
want to show you a few examples of muses
and how I'm hoping to provide case
studies of successful muses models with
all the details that you can emulate and
replicate so here are a few examples
these are real muses that have been sent
to me by readers this is I think like a
genius for example very well put
together this is everyday genius
Institute calm and it's a
subscription-based model so every month
you get something like this with a this
is a CD maybe a DVD and a guide that
allows you to model people who are the
best at what they do so in this case
it's things like a straight-a student in
past instances it has been a sommelier
for example and it's very cool
it helps you to model the best practices
of people who are the best at what they
do so this is one successful muse to be
about Erin thank you very much then a
very different example would be this
right here which is entropy so this is a
a sports drink although I wouldn't call
it a sports drink it is a B vitamin
vitamin C guarana l-carnitine green tea
etc drink that does not contain a lot of
the [ __ ] that is in drinks of this
type actually designed by a software
leave a software engineer from a very
well-known company and you can see the
packaging and everything is done very
very well so this is the box and I've
been consuming it regularly this is
empty very very well done very
professionally done so this is a very
different type of Muta certainly than
this instructional type two more that
are really textbook when you consider
the prescription in the book in terms of
targeting a specific niche and designing
for
so this is gorilla drum making gorilla
drum making comm GU er RI l la and this
is how to create a 5 piece drum set with
basic materials from Home Depot for very
very low cost drum making with realistic
tactics and realistic tools and you can
see here this what it looks like it's
very well put together you could
certainly see purchasing something like
this at a Borders Books or Barnes &
Noble it's packaged well enough that it
could sell it retail button most of it I
would imagine is direct sales okay
that's one along the same lines you have
this for example this is a crossfit
fundamentals video from crossfit Palo
Alto comm and both of these offer
products that are very high value
potentially high retail price in some
cases high production cost if you don't
control the costs but if you control
your costs low unit cost of production
all right so this is a very much a
textbook markup for product of high
value that can be low production cost
and very easy to test with this type of
media as well and last but not least I
want to show an example of perhaps a
traditional career shift that could also
double as a muse this is a book called
food heroes very very cool book by
Georgia Pellegrini here Georgia
Pellegrini comm and this book profiles
16 culinary artisans preserving
traditions and different types of
professionals or specialists and
different types of cooking and what
they're preserving the traditions are
preserving this is through a traditional
publisher beautiful book really really
beautifully done
and in this case you're looking at
certainly the royalties from the book
itself but then indirectly you have the
speaking engagements and so forth and so
on Georgia has a lot of very very cool
stuff coming so these are a number of
very different examples but they share
commonalities and I think one of the
stumbling blocks that people have with
with muses in particulars how to get
started what are this
civics what's the hosting company what's
the contract manufacturer those types of
details so what we'll be doing hopefully
in the next few weeks in the next few
months is showcasing muses that work and
giving you some of the nitty-gritty
details behind the curtains showing you
how it's done so if you have that type
of music reiated something that is
working then please submit your details
and I will be happy to promote you to
hundreds of thousands and potentially
millions of people that is all hopefully
this will help a lot of people and also
help promote some muses that are worthy
of attention out there so thanks for
listening and upward and onward